yeah oops welcome to this video I'm
playing song oh hmm let's play who first
saw probably saw cugat all sound sound
cool got down I don't know okay let's
put out some nights that can do good
things here we have a tango Black
Knights tango now I have played this
opening a couple of times and no serious
tournament chess and it's not bad at all
you can you can play it b6 now this is
rare don't get that too often yeah I
shouldn't play d5 now it's a slightly
inaccurate now probably not see six if
he takes on d6 Wow and so quickly plate
hmm ok you know and maybe he was
committed to that i don't know i don't i
don't know but it's clear that this is
not Rukia Queen a5 is so what just one
idea all kinds of technical ideas maybe
Queen 21 d 5 now
so f 54 is there some some better move
Queen a five in this case looks looks
bit bit dodgy now probably at five so
not bad at all anyway it's a good
development and Queen B sixes an idea or
simply d6 try to attack it with Bishop
you six again not sure a retrospective
really partisan really provocative we
don't develop today or what okay so
Queen B 6 you're going to play III year
yeah it's not immediately lost I
anything if I believe look so okay it
looks weird but it's maybe no direct
refutation we defer night too d-force as
a move that would be nice but Queenie
five is just too much he's got the same
III years the movie is going to Plame
hmm
No
okay I'm spending too much time here
trying to refute this directly and maybe
there is no direct refutation sometimes
it really looks like he should explode
instantly but that simply isn't isn't
the direct wave however bad it may look
I mean you played three times the same
night all kinds of pawn moves and on top
of the Queen a couple of times it cannot
be really good but then maybe it is not
so bad that it can be reviewed it
instantly now III and back or something
should be still playable for wider
course
what does this necessary why are you
doing that maybe I don't don't
understand anything here hmm we have
both for captures look good actually I
don't know they both look good
it also opens up the D file maybe mouse
mouse slip or something I mean there's
really no rational explanation for the
smooth why would you do that I thought
just III and dropping the Queen back
yeah this should be six and probably
route d8 coming with with the temple
this should be lost almost don't really
see him how to even get the pieces out
halfway decently there's no further
information in there okay this should be
right when some really lots of time
right but here here maybe a there is
some the moment to briefly check how to
proceed maybe this one attending Bishop
Knight 95 and getting getting quickly to
the king could be could be good way to
play Knights even um this is really a
finger fella yes of course night c-45
first this was of course the idea ha um
quick
ah this is really annoying I just forgot
to play this move ok so mmm what do I do
now okay that's probably the wisest to
just play this end game that's not them
bad at all I saw rock do you one but
this is probably bad at the end of my
night is stranded yeah just got to play
95 crazy
hmm
and now he allows that and this is
really cool don't understand anything
help it's all about this check on on d3
one night b3 this is why 95 was so good
yeah d five maybe oh no help what a
mouse lip group d 4 instead of Ruby g5
crazy can I Wow continue maybe this one
uh-uh I don't even have no I don't even
have no idea I don't even have my
default check Jesus okay take this I'm
sorry ah body and laughed so hard Christ
I'm sorry sorry for that what is he
doing overstepping time now and I can't
believe I'm I really have some serious
player would be weird um maybe him
climb morning hmm
yeah I don't I don't know what what's
going on in this game okay first I do
this this further than this one instead
of instead of the planned route g5 yeah
I don't even know if he has to move here
and just just attack further okay 2-5
according to computer I think I need
something to drink em some of my voice
failed on me thanks for watching